good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday happy
taylor swift day
happy happy happy turtleneck day claude
and i are both wearing turtlenecks it's
inside the toaster
studio oh yes also yesterday we were
both wearing um
blazers buzzers i feel as though we're
both so
simpatico erotico
hypnotico i wear a turtleneck
specifically this one like almost every
day so you're kind of like
just catching up that would be like if i
wore you know culottes like i would
never
hurtful no that's like your thing no and
by the way i will have you know
that when i had to clean out my closets
for the move i do believe the culottes
did not make the cut
oh my god original toasters
will remember the culottes what i like
to call gaucho pants
um that really kind of shaped the toast
in its early stages
mostly because i wore them on the first
day of the morning toast
and you wore them a lot like those first
few months yeah you know those were a
hard first two months and sometimes
sometimes you just can't help but put on
your culottes and i feel like for other
people it's like oh i'm having a hard
time let me turn to my sweatpants
and like listen to music no no but like
in terms of fashion choices yeah you
know like your
your choices reflect the way that you're
feeling yeah for me like i
turned to the cooler i turned to the
culottes the culottes were my sweatpants
of the day
and i'm not proud of it like why i think
it's great
at least it shows like you're
interesting like i've literally never
worn a pair of pants that pants
that wasn't like black leggings or black
jeans and like you're out here just like
taking risks did they did it work
no but you were so sure of yourself that
you just like took risks
and put on a pair of pants very few
people would ever put on and i think
that makes you interesting
and fabulous wow that is such a nice
compliment thank you
no it's true i'll take it like literally
people maybe have not noticed i've
literally wore these leggings
every single day this week and last week
we love to see it i always i'm always
wearing these lightings too and i just
i thought i don't know i was going for
like a mule day but my the color of my
ankles are
scary like pink and purple yeah my skin
because i didn't get that like you know
i usually get
sun once a year and now i didn't get my
yearly sun i'm turning green yeah
it's time for some self like fake tanner
yeah
yeah i reached this point last year it
ain't easy being green
speaking of the grin well that's kermit
the frog but sure speaking of green no
speaking of
being green and not having an easy go of
it speaking of speaking of fictional
green characters
um yes i actually am so glad you brought
that up because i really did not want to
bring my recap of
the very small portion of the grinch
that i watched i didn't want to drag it
into the tv recap segment
because that's like a sacred place i
just wanted to get it out right now um
and really just
shame on nbc seriously like first of all
i put it on an hour late because like i
don't i didn't care
and it was a scene without matthew
morrison and you'd think like it would
be you know
better it was just like
besides matthew morrison like it was
horrible like explain to me you know how
like the whos all have like noses that
are like
turned out turned up yeah yeah they
turned the [ __ ] out so they not only
gave all the who's
turned up noses they also gave all the
who's like big fat asses
like they had like curves it was it was
crazy like
literally everyone had like a huge huge
hips and it was like everyone was shaped
like pear
which was like such an odd choice
because like matthew maris marston's
like running around the stage with like
a
big juicy ass and it was like so
disarming
the grinch did have a big juicy ass but
it was this was like
so overt like it like it was just so
bizarre he literally looked like someone
like
like a like a baby with like a big
diaper you know like
it was so weird and then so it was just
like really poorly done i'm sorry i have
to say
and then matthew martin came down the
chimney and like my life was ruined
he was being so extra like you and like
first of all he was completely disguised
but his voice he really didn't do a good
job of like nailing the grinch voice so
it was like it was mr shoe like
his voice just sends a chill down my
spine and it's so
distinct that it was i mean i don't know
what the team at nbc is thinking right
now but it was a big fat failure and i
was reading tweets all night and it was
so funny like i just love when we can
all come together to like make fun of
something you know that's so funny i
caught bits and pieces really not a lot
i did see matthew morrison
and i just feel like there were so many
people there are so many people who
would have been amazing at it and even
just thinking that like i didn't come
prepared with a list of people but like
hugh jackman wow yeah would have crushed
it zac efron
yeah but it's like a weird role you have
like that's why jim carrey made the
grinch so iconic is like
you have to be like you can't be like so
hollywood like you have to just like be
a freak like yeah
and matthew martin tried so hard to be
that but he just is so crazy
yeah honestly i don't even know if hugh
jackman would have been good at it the
reason why the grinch is
in my opinion like irrep
irreplaceable is because jim carrey like
no one can do it like him so also like
why not jim carrey yeah he's around
yeah he doesn't sing i don't think
anyone can sing if you try hard enough
there's always gonna be another mountain
so i just wanted to get that out
um my tv recap with the salt lake city
and oc jack and i both watched josie
even though we promised that we wouldn't
um we'll do that in the tv recap i just
wanted to get it out there like i'm
sorry to everyone who was traumatized
um by that performance last night and
honestly it's been such a hard year
i find it really i don't know i find it
shocking that
that the executives over at nbc would
like intentionally want to hurt us
yeah yeah it's not nice it ain't right
it ain't right
well at least it's behind us you know
like i feel like there was so much all
of this like momentum
up to this and now it's behind us and we
can all like look ahead to 2021
yeah and we're looking ahead to tomorrow
which taylor swift announced this
morning she's a new album
we will go into all of that that's why
i'm wearing my carnigan
getting in my car again remember what i
said about anyone singing
um yeah no we're gonna be talking about
that forever more
and also oh last night i had just a
sublime evening if i may
um i hosted oh yeah taylor's
feeling okay also i want to have you
like won't come over
so and i came to you on monday night i
have never been invited
that's not true you invited me on monday
night after we had a plan to get
together at my house
which you invited yourself over like you
made the plans and then tried to flip a
switch
you tried to be the princess switch i
don't remember that way princess i
remember that's the rest of the
world that's exactly how it happened
okay the rest i don't that's but anyways
so i every time i go over to olivia's
like i'm just so hungry and she makes
such good foods i wanted to
provide that experience for her and i
cooked up a feasty vibe
and i used like all of my fancy dishes
and it was so fabulous and sensational
you'll have to come over sometime i
think you would have really liked the
cuisine chicken and pasta
yum my two favorite food groups yeah yum
well thanks for not inviting me i
i really like i appreciate it you know
you'll definitely be not invited again
no and that means so much to me and just
it's good to know where we stand
yes definitely um and tonight's the
first night of hanukkah
oh yes if you're celebrating hanukkah
toaster make sure to light those candles
and publicize the nace
it is so important more than ever it
always feels like to publicize a nation
be proud
to be jewish dreidel drain on dreidel
i made you out of clay and
when it's dr we really need to redo that
song because like there's so many good
christmas carols
and that's our one song and it's just
like so sophomoric it's like
it's the same tune as like twinkle
twinkle little star
yeah no it's the same tune as like
something
[Music]
but it's it's a familiar to you and it
just goes round and round we need to
like honestly like have
someone work on it like a like a jewish
musician honestly like
no i was gonna say hame but they're not
my style who's like a really
um popular jewish i heard somewhere
shawn mendes is like half jewish
yeah but same with harry styles oh
hairstyles yeah yeah that'd be good like
just give us like a revamp i'm so over
this one tune and it's like
the only one that's like become even
remotely mainstream and it's just like
i don't feel like it represents us as a
culture and like how cool we are i
actually love this song and i feel like
i'm always singing it because whenever
i ring up snatcher i'm like satchel or
snatcher snatcher
i made you out of scratch and when your
snatch is
ready a snatcher
i shall play
maybe we could be the ones to jazz it up
i'm going to get my guitar
for a good jam session by the way i kept
saying publicize the nace and for those
who don't know me it's publicized the
miracle ness is miracle and the miracle
of you know the candles lasting
so you put your oil lasting yeah so you
put your menorah in the window to
publicize the miracle of hanukkah just a
little
fun fact and i live in a bunker with no
windows so it's hard for me to publicize
the names oh my god now that i have so
many windows i literally i'm gonna put a
menorah in each one just publicis
publicity i'm happy for you i'm the pr
person for commenting i'm happy for you
in all your windows
you should come over actually in my
journey to like maybe moving
um i looked in an apartment yesterday
that um i really like the building
because i actually like have a bunch of
friends who live in the building which
sounds so fun to me
um and you know when like you want
something to like just work
so badly yeah the apartment was just not
it except it had like the biggest
kitchen i'd ever seen in a new york city
apartment it had like a
a formal dining room and then like a
place in the kitchen to like put a table
which is breakfast
which is insane like that's just not a
thing um
and i just i wanted it to be the right
apartment it just like would have been
so easy if the first one i
but it wasn't i'm sorry it was really
upsetting i got my hopes like way high
up i just want you know like i've gotten
the
the boys hopes up and the boys being the
pups
and our husbands and i feel like the
toasters now too that like we live in
the same building soon i tried
yeah you're we're gonna have to try
again what do you want to do build a new
unit
just like be patient for something to
come on the market see that's
i'm so glad you brought that up the one
thing i don't have right now
ever ever is patience it's like it's
probably one of my worst qualities about
like how impatient i am
yeah and it it impacts every facet of my
life like work
personal like i just am so [ __ ]
impatient like
i can't wait for anything okay fine
i'll tell them to speed it up maybe if
you could just like be a terrible
neighbor and encourage some of your
other people in the building to move out
i know only people though in a two
bedroom okay fine i'm gonna work on it
we're gonna we're gonna make this happen
for you i found a great apartment
in olivia's building no pets oh which is
like that is just so
unbelievably disgusting that oh my god i
would never even i would never even want
to support a building like that you
shouldn't even hear those words no i
know
oh my god vile vile behavior so sick
okay well we need to get into things
because we have a jam-packed fast five
stories today like that even one had to
get cut wow no it's
one of the ones i sent no okay good but
without further ado it is time for the
past life stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
palmer's the number one cocoa butter
brand
introduces their new hemp oil collection
palmer's new hemp oil calming relief
body lotion and body oil
calms susan hydrates even your driest
skin with a special blend of 100 natural
hemp seed oil and skin nourishing cocoa
butter
for highly effective skin healing it's
ideal for sensitive and eczema prone
skin
providing dry skin relief with its
powerful moisturizers their hemp oil
body oil soothes irritation
boosts hydration and improves skin's
texture and radiance
the hemp oil body lotion clinically is
proven to
help irritation dryness and itching you
can double up and layer the lotion on
top of the oil for maximum hydration
the palmer's hemp oil skin care
collection is dermatologist tested
hypoallergenic and safe for sensitive
skin you can find these products
in store and online at walmart target
walgreens or amazon
for less than ten dollars each from
palmer's the best brand
palmers choose what's real love it
reminds me of simon
van kempen's iconic song i am real that
was obviously inspired by the palmer's
hemp oil collection
yes and speaking of iconic music oh
great transition surprise more new
taylor swift music is on its way
uh today just over four months after she
released her album folklore
the grammy winner announced that another
album her ninth studio album is on the
way
titled evermore the so-called sister
album to folklore drops later tonight at
midnight
eastern time so taylor posted on her
instagram that evermore
is coming she said to put it plainly we
just couldn't stop writing songs
to try and put it more poetically it
feels like we were standing on the edge
of the folklorian wards
and had a choice to turn and go back or
to travel further into the forest of
this music
we chose to wander deeper in let me
let me just try and explain how i'm
feeling please please
par of course like on the surface i'm so
excited like
all i ever want is taylor swift music i
feel like so many fandoms get like so
much music from their favorite artists
and it's like
i waited like two years after for
reputation and then two years like
it's so exciting i feel like an ariana
grande fan like we just get so much
music and so
on the surface i'm like so so excited
especially because like folklore
is really like in terms of genre like
one of my favorites especially given the
year that we've had
and i'm just looking forward to getting
another 15 songs similar to folklore
also i looked at the track titles and a
lot of them definitely seemed like
things i would be interested in like i
love a song just named after a woman so
we have dorothy
what is that about who knows we also
have margaery who knows
we also have a song called the last
cowboy which
i just know is going to be it's going to
be betty vibes like that's what i'm
getting for sure wow
we're also getting a music video tonight
for the song willow which i just love
the name willow
so there's a lot to be excited about
there is and i personally just want to
say i'm excited about the title of this
album because for those of you who are
familiar with the ghost of snitch's past
she haunts the halls of the house we
rented in utah forever
and i just love that it's so spooky it's
such a great word and i'm glad that it
will be like
it also reminds me of that josh groban
song from beauty and the beast a
stunning song if you don't know it
so yes i'm here for all those things how
else are you feeling no i think if i
unpack my feelings a little bit more
like i woke up and i was just like
feeling very overwhelmed
that's what i was thought you were like
i don't know what time she posted eight
and i woke up
like i was on my phone by like 8 45 and
i was just getting inundated with like
dm's like wake up wake up
and it's like i just felt like very
anxious and now i'm just feeling
overwhelmed because you have work to do
this weekend in
digesting a whole new album no it's like
i wasn't even gonna stay up till
midnight tonight but like now i have to
and it's like my sleep is so important
to me these days
and i just i don't know i think if i
really like think about how i feel i'm
feeling very overwhelmed like i don't
even know
if i've had enough time to sit with
folklore and i've listened to folklore
so much but like
still it's like i'm especially after the
new disney plus thing like i'm learning
more about other songs and like i'm
listening to this is me trying so much
more and that was a song i used to skip
like i'm just i'm feeling overwhelmed
like that's the only word i can use like
i'm i'm overwhelmed well i feel like i
understand why you're overwhelmed but i
feel like because this is a sister album
like you'll spend the weekend listening
to this you'll be
introduced to these songs and then
eventually you'll listen to folklore and
evermore together
because they should be the same vibe
their sister albums she also sisters
just like us
and we love sisters and we're sisters
who support other sisters therefore we
have to support folklore never more
very true very true also there are some
collabs on the album yes bonnie bear
shows up again
love they obviously work great together
again haim shows up again
how are you feeling i'm not a big haim
fan but taylor can make me like anyone
so like whatever i'm like obviously like
the biggest national fan now
and the national is also doing a collab
which is exciting because aaron destner
who was in the folklore for people who
like aren't really like insular like in
the taylor swift world let me explain it
to you
in the disney plus documentary that guy
aaron destler who like created a lot of
the songs with taylor and jack
is a part of a band called the national
so now i guess he's was working on
folklore more as a producer and now he's
like a full-on collaborator like him and
his band i don't know if other people
are in the national but i think there's
probably a few guys i'm sure
yeah i think well that's right because
he said like that's how they write songs
like yeah his band cause like i just
found out that like um
panic at the disco is just like one guy
really yeah there's no band it's just
brendon urie
that's like his stage name that doesn't
sound like what i thought
no same it was like shocking when i
found out stitch told me oh so i'm
pretty sure that
bonnie bear is a band and justin's lead
singer
no i think so i i was doing some
investigative work
just wait i'm gonna i'm googling it
because i wasn't even investigating i
just stumbled on it
oh that just doesn't sound familiar it's
an american indie folk band
founded by justin vernon
i'm just going to choose to it's a band
they said the thing is it's like that's
categorizes band that very well
may be true i just will not continue on
like i don't want to change because i
already
think it doesn't work for me bunny
bear's a guy and it's like i'll know
that that's wrong but i'm just like
really not interested in like resetting
how i see
bony beard you know what i mean yeah no
i understand it's too much for one day
it's
so much like i'm so overwhelmed like i'm
just
that's just don't even say like i'm
that's too much for me okay okay
so that was like when i found out that
like the lead singer of rascal flatts's
name was not rascal it was gary like
that was a huge shake-up yeah and you're
just finishing processing that i'm still
not over it
what's the point in naming your band
that's what's confusing boney bear like
that does sound like a name kind of
kind of but like rascal flat says like
literally naming your band claudia
ostrich like
that makes no [ __ ] sense that's not a
whole name
rascal flats that's not someone's like
real name
why not it could be but it's not like oh
that's an that's not like john smith
no that it's literally john smith rascal
is such a common name
flats is a last name rascal's not a name
it's not a common name wait
what wait
[Music]
what i can't even get into your
mindset that rascal could be someone's
name
what like it could be like tree could be
someone's name
wait like rascal's like a name like a
rougher
[Applause]
it's a mischievous or cheeky person
especially a child or a man so like
no one's gonna name their kid rascal
you're so
right oh my god oh my god
yeah that i'm saying the word so much i
see how you thought it was a name
no like
i can't even explain what i'm feeling
right now like i'm so upset
oh my god this whole time i don't know i
saw the word rascal with the capital r
and i'm like oh it's like a name like
robert
like roberts
oh my god i sound so stupid i've said
this like so many times i've never
really dug deeper
[Music]
i guess that's a bunch of kids who are
being mischievous
oh god oh my god
i'm just learning so much today that's
like really shaking up my psyche so like
now are you feeling overwhelmed i'm
feeling so uneasy like
everything you thought was just so upset
like
everything you thought you knew is being
involved no it's like the way that i saw
the world is completely different
now than it was ten minutes ago yeah
sometimes that can happen that happened
to me with dachshund like i'm telling
you that was crazy did you see there was
a document in salt lake city last night
in one of the b-rolls there was adoption
running across the world i don't watch
b-roll like i'm always scrolling on my
phone oh that's funny
oh my god i'm shook up by that we're
just gonna give you a minute to process
that
no i'm okay like
you know what rascal is a similar word
too i feel like
snitch it's also like scoundrel so i
guess if there was a band called
snitches ain't like i would think that
that was weird that's a full name
that's a person to me first name cinch
is last name i know her
yeah of course oh my god okay so
evermore comes out tonight everyone
stream it
and um i'm actually curious just like
from the business side of things like
um will she be able to sell over a
million copies which is like her thing
most of her albums have
um but because she releases an album
once every two years like will she be
able to do that twice in a year yes
that'll be crazy yes because folklore
was so successful
was so successful people are saying this
is folklore part two okay everyone who
subscribed to part one is gonna be
interested in part two
yeah and if the music is good the music
speaks for itself you're right
you can't get people to like buy like
it's so crazy how that happens like
i actually on the one hand i feel like
sometimes people put out bad music and
like
it becomes popular yeah but like
sometimes you put out a bad album and
like the people respond art pop
you know well that was like we've been
sitting on that no but like you know
what i mean you can't just like put out
an album
and expect it to like soar unless it's
really really good
yeah but then even still people put out
really really good albums that just flop
which is so crazy
but that's because we live in a
generation of people who have no taste
lotus christine aguilera justice for it
i feel like in a lot of ways joanne
wasn't successful
but it was stunning but it was stunning
beautiful stunning and smart
there's just like a few of those that
like honestly i think one of the
greatest albums of all time is native by
one republic
and like nobody's ever heard of it yeah
but they know the songs from the
commercials on abc
yes i got my mind made up
and i can't let go i'm feeling so uneasy
like you know what like i was already
feeling uneasy when we started the show
because i'm having like
such cramps i've tried to hide it from
you guys but i couldn't i'm the american
cramper
all of the laughter it's like it's
shaking up my cramps
it's truly what they say laughter is the
best medicine it's not like that my
cramps have gone away but now they're
like a little disoriented they're like
what's this other pain in the belly no i
think that cramps like feed off of your
depression so like honestly your
endorphins are now like kicking in yeah
and they're just combating cramps
right next to my middle middle my doll
my doll i remember in the beginning of
quarantine when i thought that you
couldn't take my doll because of the
acetaminophen
and um you weren't taking it i didn't
take it for my first quarantine period
and then i realized like i got my things
mixed up that's crazy i don't take
middle middle is everything you need to
give it you need to be patient with it
30 40 minutes
solves all your problems really helps
all of your i'm just like an advil queen
but i didn't stop taking advil for like
everything in my life so you're not
supposed to take advil when you're
on it's a blood dinner because it will
it's a blood thinner so it affects your
flow flow and a wide set vagina
and flow is also another prestigious end
yes yeah and you know she gets a bad rap
maybe that's why she's
she comes for hard for me because she's
like you're too good of an end like i'm
the number one where i'm at and that's
what she does she's trying to toughen
you up because being an auntie is a lot
of work
[Laughter]
it's true it's true okay ready for our
next story
yes tiffany haddish turned down hosting
the grammy's pre-telecast and here's why
tiffany haddish was asked to host the
grammys pre-telecast premiere ceremony
but the comedy superstar she turned down
the offer
when the recording academy told her that
she had to pay her
own way no yeah like not get a salary
not only did they ask her to host the
three-hour livestream event without any
compensation but she tells variety that
they wouldn't cover hair makeup or
wardrobe for the three-hour event three
hours oh my god that sounds like torture
she said all that would have all that
would have had to come out of my pocket
i don't know if this might mean i might
not ever get nominated again but i think
it's disrespectful
i totally agree yes for context the uh
pre-show it's not hosted by it's not
like organized by cbs it's done by the
academy
which is a not-for-profit organization
so all hosts presenters and performers
have traditionally performed gratis
including this year
okay does that mean the person who hosts
the grammys real show doesn't get paid
or does cbs pay them oh i don't know
that's a good question but like
obviously presenters performers don't
get paid and i guess that would
translate over to red carpet hosts even
though i feel like they're the hardest
working people there
yeah i mean okay now that okay i guess
the recording academy like technically
yes is a non-profit
it doesn't give off like non-profit
vibes no it doesn't by any means
they're big fancy television it's just
very profitable vibes it gives off like
very like private equity vibes okay
so i don't know i think asking people to
work for free
is a big thing in hollywood but like
it's more so when you're up and coming
so it's like
honestly tiffany haddish would be doing
the grammys a favor by lending her name
and likeness to this pre-show telecast
that i never even heard of you know what
i mean yeah so it's like
okay if someone like a digital star or
like a rising host
got this opportunity they would do it
for free because it's worth
their time for the opportunity tiffany
honest doesn't need this she's one of
the biggest comedians in the world
so they should really just be like it is
disrespectful
you know i understand that they're not
going to pay people to do their red
carpet but then you gotta
lower your standards yeah no no i
understand you're not gonna pay people
so don't ask
the biggest comedian in the world like
yeah maybe i'll do it
yeah no you know what i mean like it's
it is disrespectful just to like offer
someone a job for no money like
seems [ __ ] up like yeah especially
someone who
doesn't need to do this it's like
they don't need it to tiffany haddish
will be just as relevant
whether and famous whether or not she
hosts this telecast or not yeah
yeah that that is really interesting
though and i feel like a lot of times
there are sort of these question marks
you see they're like with these big
opportunities they're either getting
paid so much money
or they're not getting paid at all right
because it's like okay there's someone
hosting the oscars like when kevin hart
was
wow my water bottle just like popped
like when kevin hart was supposed to
host it like
in a lot of ways he's always said that
was like his biggest dream he would do
it for free
but it's also like the biggest job in
the world so like who has more money
than the oscars
yeah so i don't know i always think that
too like when you go on
jimmy fallon like a super bowl for
example it's so much work but it and
like
you're giving the performance of a
lifetime so on the one hand you should
be paid millions of dollars
but on the other hand it's a stage like
no other you're going to hit the top of
the itunes charts so
they don't get paid are you sure yes but
it's sponsored by pepsi so i would feel
like pepsi would pay people
to use their name and likeness in
association with pepsi brand i
the super bowl performers do not get
paid like last time i thought about this
but let me just double check
i feel like that's actually one they
would get paid for only because it's
sponsored
verbal performers paid
i i feel like i feel like they do
they're not paid to perform according to
cnbc
okay yeah i just have things like do
people get paid to go on ellen or jimmy
fallon i don't know
right i don't i don't i think in general
like
getting paid to do press is not done a
thing
i agree or like do you get pt on the
cover of a magazine yes
so that's where it gets confusing but
that's because you tell your story
right and like you have day rates for
like the photo shoot
yeah it's confusing yeah the line is
super blurry
like a true a-lister to come on the show
and just like spit like what do you get
paid for what do you get paid for like
what do you pay for yourself
what could you get paid for yeah and
it's like okay if you have a music label
and like
like do they pay for your like suburbans
like i just have questions
yeah you know suburban people come
people are always rolling around in
suburbans and i'm just curious who's
footing the bill
and is it uberx hell right that's a
great question because when i'm in the
suburban it's always super excel i also
feel like
um a lot of times these days it is uber
xl like
yeah yeah yeah but now it's uber xl yeah
i agree i'm just i'm
i find celebrity culture to be so
interesting but i really find like the
logistics
to be even more interesting like how do
you get from place to place like when
celebrities hang out
do you guys text each other or do the
managers text each other i think it's a
combination but i'm just curious when
chrissy tegan does a really good job of
letting
people into the logistics of being a
celebrity yeah she remember when she
used to do those q and a's so she needs
to do another one
yeah okay this next story anyway so
bottom line like if you want tiffany
haddish to
do your red carpet like yeah because and
if you don't have a budget that's
totally understandable as a non-profit
but reach out
to some hosts who could use the exposure
yeah dream smaller
yeah okay next story is like really
amazing news for jessica simpson
i know amazon is prepping jefferson
simpson docuseries and scripted series
based on her memoir as part of a
multimedia rights deal
so jessica simpson is just having a
great week
she sold she literally sold the rights
to her book which like every author
tries to do and she sold it to amazon
studios like that is just
what's better no there's and after her
book had like the most amazing year so
amazon is opening the book on jessica
simpson after striking a broad
multimedia rights deal with the pop and
reality tv star
the streamer is working on an unscripted
docu-series based on simpson's memoir
open book
so does that mean like a reality show
that's what i was confused about because
it's like okay it's a piece of content
based on her life
her previous life like in her that she
already wrote about but then it's also
unscripted so
a reality show based on what already
happened yeah it's not reality
no i feel like it's a reality show of
her now just like yeah they're using
buying the book rights to justify it and
then also
a scripted a coming-of-age scripted
series inspired by the book which
early 20s like rising to fame that
sounds so
good so so good yeah i'm really excited
about this
open book was truly one of the best
books i read all year except for mine
which i don't know if i've spoken about
today
uh i'm writing a book it's very exciting
oh [ __ ] already
it's all right it's all in here the ink
is dry it's called girl with no job the
crazy
beautiful life of an instagram thirst
monster it is available for pre-order
anywhere you can get books e-books
audiobooks and hardcover books
amazon barnes and noble audible all the
places if you go to the link girl with
no job.com
book you'll get all the links and i
would really appreciate you supporting
the book i'm a first time author i'm
very excited about it
jackie has read the book she actually
has a blurb on the back theo was also on
the back so which is truly a family
affair
check it out girl with no job.com book
yes jessica simpson's book was one of
the best things i read all year
and now it's just gonna be like the gift
that keeps on giving because we're
getting more content from it
yes and more content from her also just
want to say
redhead's episode just dropped i dropped
it yesterday because it was like early
but also still
six days late um invisible life of addie
lavroa was the book we read this month
we're recapping it
the book was so good and i think it was
one of my favorite episodes that we've
done this year one because
of the great recap but two we shared all
of our other papers
and i don't want to spoil anything but
open book by jessica simpson was one of
my top three books
of the year that i read non-redheads did
you um add my book even though it's not
published yet no because we tried to do
like 20 20 titles
so so hurtful but your 2021 title why
would you want to be like
looped into this year i don't know just
like any air time for my book is
genuinely we did talk about the fact
that you next month we're going to be
super exciting because one
we're doing a redheads episode first
thursday of january as always snitch's
choice for the book
i said snitch's book choice was it and
someone commented
so the book choices like with the
balloon
no it's layla by colleen hoover which is
a book that i've been seeing everywhere
it's snitch's favorite author we haven't
read a colleen hoover book yet
supposed to be like very similar to
verity which everybody loved so i'm just
really excited about that
but then we also get a bonus episode in
january because we are sitting down our
first ever author series
we're sitting down inside the inside the
redhead studio i'll wear my turtleneck
inside the red head studio we're sitting
down with first time author
claudia ashrae and we are gonna get
we're gonna be asking her the card
questions about her books so
you're gonna want to be there for that
and it's never too late to become a
redhead also i feel like this episode
that we just did
is like the perfect kind of episode that
you can listen to even if you didn't
read the book
i always give a summary of the book at
the beginning of the episode oh that's
smart and usually it's like three
minutes
this summary was like 10 minutes so
you'll know the entire book and then you
can follow along with the recap
yeah you should start doing that for
like popular books that are read in high
schools
so like a lot of high schoolers who
don't want to read the books will
literally tune into your podcast you
should do like podcast episodes about
but it's like not just it's like you got
to do the invisible case of the dog in
the middle of the night
uh portrait of dorian gray oh yeah i
actually love picture of dorian gray but
um
the odyssey iliad yeah but also it's
like we'll give you the recap but we'll
also
uh answer like dbq's as we always like
the pencil on the table
was a phallic symbol so that we have
like opinions to give you so you can
raise your hand and be
in class and be like inquisitive and
hamlet was in love with his mother
yeah but we'll have like dana really do
all that so you sound really smart
that's actually a great idea for a
podcast yeah just like
[ __ ] you need to know in high school no
like impress your professor
yeah yeah okay well you're ready for our
next story that i chose i don't know if
you've seen it and i'm hoping that i'm
about to give you some life-changing
news okay
there is an icarly revival of course
i've heard of it sorry
web show hosts keep up with other web
show hosts set
at paramount plus with original cast
members returning
i can't get too excited about these
boots because one we announce them
and i never see the actual content and
if we do it's like saved by the bell and
they're just like being cringy and
writing
jokes and then it's like the things that
i actually want to get the thing the
reboots that i'm actually excited about
hillary duff and lizzie mcguire are like
never get made so
cb yeah i just the whole reboot industry
is something that like our generation
millennials
like love and i just couldn't give less
of a [ __ ] i tell you what i do love
about the reboot industry like i love
when like it's like i carly reboot and
we get to talk about it in the show and
we get so excited cass is coming back
and then i never want to pick it up ever
again ever you know i do like then like
think just the announcing part of like
what shows are coming back but like
i just know what this is gonna be it's
going to be the cast like sitting around
on zoom
laughing about old jokes like i just i'm
not interested now here's
here's what i actually am interested in
as it pertains to the icarly reunion
the involvement of one dan schneider
yeah yeah i'm i'm not seeing his name
in this article okay but i'm
very curious about that as well they're
saying that the original series stars
miranda cosgrove jerry traynor and
nathan cress are all set to appear in
the new version
what about jeanette mccurdy they didn't
say jeanette mccurdy okay because
jeanette mccurdy
is very vocal online about you know kind
of the
traumatizing experiences she had as a
child actor
um and as it pertains to certain
producers within the network so
um that's actually crazy that she's not
going to be there because
she's just honestly after miranda
cosgrove she's the most important like
and relevant main character for sure
i also feel like icarly was so ahead of
its time like girl with a web show
yeah and now it's like if there's an
icarly in 2020 like there's a million
icarly like she's an influencer we are
all like harley yeah she's a youtuber
she might have a podcast and it's like
are they really going to delve into the
like it would actually be an interesting
show if it was a show about like
an influencer yeah tv has like
many a time tried to like emily and
paris like tried to capture
the life of like a social media star
and it's never not cringy and i would
actually be really interested to see
see it one time and not icarly but just
like one time it'd be done correctly
because it actually is like
especially people who are like really
successful at their jobs and like get
amazing opportunities
because of their instagram like it's a
super interesting life and if they're
one time like they were able to capture
it correctly even like with tana's
series on mtv which i didn't watch but i
don't think was very good
um she has such an interesting life and
it became so overproduced like i just
one time want to see like a piece of
content whether it's unscripted
or or scripted like the life of a social
media star like done right
yeah i totally agree but it's always
cringy like
be kind like it's just so lame yeah
so we'll keep you probably not posted on
this news but just always exciting
yes fifth and final story claude sent to
me some major tech news
major business major tech biz legal news
time for a little major tag biz
legal news facebook has been hit with
two
massive anti-trust lawsuits from the ftc
and 46 states are seeking to spin off
instagram and whatsapp basically just
saying
facebook owning instagram and whatsapp
is somehow a monopoly
yes right that it's too big so these are
anti-trust lawsuits
um one from the federal trade commission
and the other one from 48
state attorneys general both lawsuits
revolve around the company's
acquisitions of instagram in 2012 and
whatsapp in 2014
which at the time got regulatory
approval
but have recently come under heavy
scrutiny as people are saying like
facebook is too big and i guess one way
to just like make it smaller is to take
away those things
okay so here are my thoughts as a
consumer and just like someone who
operates in the digital space like
facebook owning whatsapp is so
irrelevant like i just have to say like
that is not a monopoly
not my problem whatsapp is a messaging
app but it's not a social media platform
it's an internet like it's just it's so
irrelevant to this conversation the real
conversation is like is facebook owning
instagram
a monopoly and i just feel like at the
time of the sale someone should have
objected
and the fact that they didn't it's like
i don't know i feel like i believe in
the rules like
they they got approved like they should
just be able to stay you know what i
mean yeah that's like annoying for like
someone to like let you like do a
certain thing and then
and take change yeah give yeah no
backsies
no backsies facebook yeah no no back to
your ftc what's actually crazy is that i
think if you look into it like the
whatsapp acquisition is actually a much
bigger deal really than instagram yeah
but just like in our worlds really
relevant irrelevant um and like
instagram feels so big to us whereas
like instagram compared to facebook is
actually like
kind of small yeah um and i i think it's
really interesting i think we're at an
interesting place in the technology
slash government landscape
i and what happens here will
will really determine like how things go
for ever
forever wait also though like now that i
think about it
facebook owning instagram like okay is
definitely a conglomerate
but i don't think i would consider it a
monopoly given like the fact that there
are a few other like big social media
players like tick tock
twitter like it's not like they're the
only two apps that are popular
google youtube google youtube right so
why is google owning youtube okay but
facebook owning instagram is not i mean
[ __ ] comparison this is what i'm
saying like this could be you know
something if if it's taken away from
them then maybe
google and youtube could be next yeah
that's interesting it'll be interesting
to watch this play out
i gotta go home and turn around and then
also it's like so if instagram is no
longer part of facebook like will it go
back to just being like a photo sharing
app and they'll stop trying to sell us
everything and they'll remember
shops from the bottom like you know they
just got like so crazy and that's a
facebook effect no you're 100
right non-chronological timeline i don't
know her
uh algorithm instagram shop even though
i love using the feature on our morning
to shop if you're looking for morning
chose merch head over to
shopmorningtoast.com
um hate the feature hey like every
fourth post ad that's a facebook feature
yeah but i also feel like instagram
became like a major
platform because of facebook's influence
you know and so
all the things that annoy us i guess
also contributed to its massive success
yeah every time they change [ __ ] up it's
like so annoying for us but it always in
the long run
it sounds like really big brother like
knows what they're doing you know yeah
but also we just like
probably become accustomed to whatever
change it is even if it's not like most
beneficial because we're addicted to
these products right that's like apple
like with all their new products like
it's so annoying
but like in the end it's like that
actually feels like technology
advancement like
you know what i mean yes yes yes um okay
well those were the fast five and i feel
like they were quite robust and you
definitely needed to know that you
needed to know them i'm not gonna lie
some days you really
don't need to know them but today you
did and now let's dive into our tv recap
we had double
back-to-back housewives last night oc
which is just getting worse and worse
and salt lake city which is just getting
better with every minute and we're going
to dive into those recaps
after today's sponsor which is brought
to you by stamps this holiday season
more people will be mailing stuff than
ever before
that means the post office is going to
be busy and you don't have time for that
stamps.com brings the post office and
now ups shipping right to your computer
mail and ship anything from the
convenience of your home or office with
stamps.com anything you can do at the
post office you can do with just a few
clicks
plus stamps.com saves you money with
deep discounts that you can't even get
at the post office
stamps.com brings the service of the us
postal service and ups right to your
computer
stamps.com is a must-have for any
business whether you're a small office
sending out invoices
an online seller fulfilling orders or
even a giant warehouse sending out
thousands of packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
use your computer to print official us
postage
24 7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup or drop it off it's that simple
and like we said you could get great
discounts with stamps.com so five cents
off every first class stamp and up to 40
off priority mail and up to 62 percent
off ups shipping rates
it's a fraction of the cost of those
expensive postage meters
it's a no-brainer saving you time and
money don't spend a minute of your
holiday season at the post office this
year
sign up for stamps.com instead there's
no risk and with our promo code
toast you get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
toast
that's stamps.com enter code toast
stamps.com
never go to the post office again all
right let's go in order real housewives
of orange county blurry episode
zoom episode everyone coming for
elizabeth vargas's throat and i'm just
like not [ __ ] here for it
everyone on this show has lied more than
anyone else and now we're just like
just like complained and been divorced
and and took years to
get to the other side and honestly um
i just like i i couldn't believe that
bronwyn stooped as low as she did as to
look up someone's financial records like
you're like she's just trying to be like
megan king edmonds who was like the pi
of the real houses of orange county
and she was annoying when she did it
megan king admins but she was always
right and also she
she came with some big stuff like to
come with the fact that elizabeth's
house is on airbnb or verbo like
who like that's so judgmental of you
especially when like you're all renting
your house
right you're all renting so like let's
just you are the airbnb
customer oh it's a pot calling the
kettle black
yeah so i'm just like it's like there's
really nothing going on this season and
i think the
women are like worried about being
boring so they're just like coming for
elizabeth vargas
and like yes she's been a little
inconsistent in like her map but she
doesn't owe these women anything and i
just feel like
they're all just accusing her of being
this like evil person just for being
like slightly inconsistent in
her retelling of history as it pertains
to her marriage when just like all these
women have done so much worse to each
other and i'm just
i'm not here for like this yeah and
honestly the only people who are really
i feel like protecting
elizabeth vargas is obviously kelly
because they're friends but then weirdly
gina like at the last minute like
turning around not going to kelly's
house and then telling
elizabeth what bronwyn did i actually
really appreciated that emily also she
told
um elizabeth what bronwyn did yeah it's
just shannon
and bronwyn yeah so a few things about
the episode first of all you can really
tell that all of the
housewives are produced by different
production companies because of the way
that they're handling
quarantine filming and like oc puts so
much emphasis on like day 10 day 20. it
was like the worst possible thing that
we could have watched like
we've been saying this whole time that
we did not want to see okay but i also
think
that they um of all the shows on bravo
they were the worst time the worst
timing in terms of like being in the
midst of filming and then having to go
out for three months
yes i i agree with that um but they
spent the whole episode with like
zoom stuff and so as it pertains to
elizabeth so i didn't wind up watching
last week and so like my
ocd is flaring up but i'm gonna go off
of what i saw
last night because i agree with you i
think they're being so hard on her and
like
not giving her like five minutes of
grace to process her divorce when like
shannon took
five seasons uh-huh gina gina's still
processing it it's so hypocritical
so hypocritical and i think gina did
apologize which i think gina like
saw her own hypocrisy yeah and did
apologize over the zoom and i forgive
her and i and i can move on from it i
think that bronwyn won bringing up those
financial records and also like
now that she's had like a few good weeks
is like being like well
like she's being an ass judgmental she
was like on my first season i was lying
like she thinks that she's like
godly now that she can like see just who
she was
for the last year and it's like that's
really great that you're in that place
but to turn around and like
use it again someone else is actually
the worst and meanest thing you could do
100 and you know what i'm really
struggling with how to feel about
bronwyn because so much of what i feel
like she's putting out is like so
authentic and i really appreciate
her transparency in in her journey but i
do feel like
she's being a little too honest and like
when she shared that she
has physically assaulted her husband
like
like that's just like not okay and like
that's definitely something you should
keep to yourself
yeah i agree i i appreciate her
being honest in front of the cameras i
think that like when you come on the
show it's like the one requirement and
she is giving us so much but i also feel
like
there are so many things it's so like
even i mean just sharing that detail
that she had
physically assaulted her husband and
multiplied
and then just moving on from that yeah
it just it i didn't know how to feel
about it yeah
and then also like her going into the
closet and talking about how she feels
trapped in her marriage like in track
like
and just it it's a little too honest
yeah it's like it's not the bronwyn and
sean reality family show
and so like to go from the those moments
to like
back to the girls and then bronwyn's
going in and like
casting judgment on elizabeth's life i'm
like this there's a lot
it's a lot i agree and you know what i
actually don't think it's funny
when like grown women don't know how to
do laundry i actually think it's like
one of the
like least funny most annoying things
and it's like bro when you're 45 years
old and you have seven kids and you
don't know how to do laundry like that's
not funny tv content that's actually
just embarrassing
yeah and it's like it's just not funny
like i don't think [ __ ] like that's
funny grown women or men
yeah i'm sorry yes i don't mean to no i
didn't think that you were the laundry
machine is a very
simple simple machine no and it's like
you literally needed to live so i don't
know how anyone could go 45 years
without knowing how to at least do
one load okay i understand you're not
doing laundry every week you have a
housekeeper that is so
acceptable but like to not literally
know how to use the machine she was
definitely like trying to be funny i i
didn't believe that she didn't know
is it a heavy loader like that was just
so stupid i hate you like that
no in in the one episode that i missed
like my feelings on bronwyn have
started to really change and i don't
know if it would have been like less of
a drastic shift if i watched last week's
episode
but i just i was so i she's been so open
and honest and
i think and it's so admirable but then
to use those learnings and
to use them against someone else i just
think that it's mean and that's not real
growth
yeah i totally agree um also
i found it i didn't like she was also
being really judgmental to kelly so
kelly is like
running around town this is the
beginning yeah flying to new york
and you would think okay bronwyn's going
to judge kelly what are you going to
judge kelly on like maybe not taking the
the pandemic seriously like flying in
the middle of a lockdown
no she's judging kelly for leaving her
kid at home
not at home with her father while she's
with rick and it's like
actually no brennan i don't agree with
you on that first of all the kid
has two parents and that's like when
people give amanda stanton [ __ ] like for
like traveling it's like no the kid has
a parent like another yeah and the kid
would be with that parent and then kelly
would be alone so she has these
two she had one week to herself what is
she gonna do she's gonna be with her man
yeah so it's just like he's also alone
bronwyn like just being so judgmental
i've never leave my kids at home alone
and then i love like seeing people on
twitter like
bronwyn said i would never leave my kids
at home no she said i would never leave
my kids in the middle of a global
pandemic
right and cut to like if you look at her
instagram she's been like although she
went to salt lake city she went to new
york like she went to dc she's been with
like
housewives from every franchise over the
last eight months which i've
actually seen and i thought was
interesting and strange but
it's even stranger coupled with the
judgments that she cast on kelly for
traveling
yeah now on a lighter note um i do think
that the pandemic
and quarantine is so good for gina
because
her extensions are out yeah and her hair
is just like not getting blown out no
heat no bleach and it's really letting
it grow
because then in her testimonial she's um
not wearing extensions it looks like her
hair has grown a little bit and it looks
very healthy
and i just want to say i'm very excited
about the prospect of gina's hair you
know having a good day but i'm nervous
because i saw a comment on instagram
where she said that her hair like
get brace herself because her hair is
going to get worse this season it was
from a few weeks ago and so i feel like
maybe when the salons open back up she
gets a little too excited yeah
i'm nervous that's bad but i agree with
you like seeing her short hair like
there's nothing you could do for your
hair that's better than just
chopping it off and just not touching it
like no heat
and no no coloring and i just i think
this is very exciting i think it could
be very good for her
yeah also oh sorry you go shannon
yeah like having that like meeting like
first day back and we're just gonna like
come in with all the things people have
been
dming us about elizabeth over the last
three months
also her being like i have pi's like no
you have people who are sending you
instagram dms yeah
it's not that impressive also i do feel
really bad for shannon because she's
taking the virus so seriously because
she's
immunocompromised but i also feel like
she's um
really like uh panicky in the sense like
she's
like her kids look up to her she had so
many people in her house and i feel like
she's like making everyone scared like
yes what's the word i'm looking for like
where you're hypochondriac
no but it's like you're inducing like
where you're
like a mom is supposed to calm everyone
down and she's like making everyone so
nuts
yeah like almost like not instigating
but like like inciting fear like yes you
know what i mean i do know what you mean
and i'm like on the phone just like
screaming crying it's like i understand
that it's scary and that you have some
more to lose and you're
and i totally get that but she worries
me
no i agree and i understand she was in
her home and she had these very strict
rules and i think that's very fair but
like when her daughter
tested positive and she's on the phone
like hyperventilating screaming crying
to kelly and i was almost like mad at
her
child like for getting sick well her
kids were being irresponsible running
out of the house when they when they
have a mom
who's very at risk and you're running to
a party like
in the middle like that wasn't cool yeah
no it wasn't cool but like
that's just the way that she was
handling it and also like when they
flashed back to all of the other times
where she's overreacted
yes about stuff my left eyes it just
it's like calm down shannon she was
really being a karen like yeah she
is the karen yeah no and i thought that
way i felt that way about like her at
costco
that's what you said last week and i
totally saw just the way that she like
her she's
such high alert and and by the way and
that's not to say like what's going on
isn't scary it
especially at in march it was very scary
especially for someone with a lung
problem
i just feel like you know as like the
leader of her household she really just
needs to like take it easy
yeah she's that's like not a way to live
is to like be so panicked living in fear
and make everyone else so panicked too
yes
um also just emily just remains the
queen of my heart and soul
watching her and shane like have a great
few months together
was so nice and i really think they're
so cute
it's just so funny because it really
shows like how reality tv editing can
make it look one way or the other
because it's like we're now at two
extremes
one where was like this marriage isn't
gonna last and now it's like they're so
cute he's vacuuming you know
yeah i actually just really like them
and i feel like they've editing has like
left him alone this season and like he
just doesn't really get involved
um and i think it's really good for
their marriage and i'm just like i'm so
happily happy for emily
yes i agree um so other than that i was
just like
having ptsd i was having so much ptsd
also from like the different
stages of like information that we knew
like even when kelly was in
times square and obviously she's not
wearing a mask but that was because that
was a time when like you were encouraged
not to wear them when the women met up
in the park and i'm like
girls put your masks on but it was
literally like april
and that was when there was like a
shortage of masks and if you were
wearing one that was like a huge phone
you were taking one away from someone
who needed it more than you so
like just watching how our
culture culture and like the information
that we have has changed over time it
was just like
it was definitely bringing back to a
dark place not gonna lie yeah it was
very dark and i'm just really looking
forward to like
them being out of quarantine and like
yeah that's a little like outrageous
great can't wait
now let's just transition to like the
literal premier franchise like the
diamond in bravo's portfolio
real housewives of salt lake city which
last night again didn't disappoint never
does never could
love the women so much the luncheon we
picked up part two of the luncheon and
things definitely got weird
i at first was really on mary's side um
and now i've completely turned on mary
literally that's the thing about
salt lake city is like in the beginning
i was so
unclear on who i like and now most of
i've settled in on who i like
but mary and jen i just the thing about
a new franchise like we're still not
cemented
in our feelings about people and i agree
i was on mary's side and then she
couldn't
she couldn't accept and maybe there were
things that we didn't see at the
table because i was watching watch what
happens live with lisa and meredith and
obviously i think there was way more
conversation but like part of
being like right is accepting an apology
and moving on no but see
i i was with mary until a certain point
because mary didn't get an apology
meredith did yes yes
so it's like all gen i could tell like
mary was annoyed it's like you're gonna
have this kumbaya moment and not even
acknowledge me and not even give me an
apology and this is my luncheon and i
just gave you a little
time so it's like i understood but then
she just took it to a place that was
uh unacceptable right and so the lunch
went sideways and
i don't think it accomplished but i
think it started out really nice and it
didn't accomplish what it set out to but
what i was saying about opinions
changing about people like i'm on this
journey with lisa
yeah because when i watch the first
episode i was like i think she's going
to be one of my favorites
and then i saw her watch what happens
live and i'm like no she wants this too
bad
yeah but then in the last few episodes
like her crying with marriage greed
and her like just talking like in like
some of the conversations with her
husband
i'm like there's something really sweet
and endearing about her and i feel like
she's a good friend but then also i
don't like the way that she treats
whitney or heather yeah
she's definitely like a little bit of a
thirst monster with her emphasis on on
sundance
right and so like i was feeling really
conflicted but i was starting to feel
like you know what i want to
make this work i want to make it work
and so her and meredith wear and watch
what happens live and so i was like i
want to watch her on watch outside maybe
it will
undo the opinion of the last watch what
happens live and
she like first saw the two of them like
looked amazing they were so cute
meredith cut her hair so now it's like
way easier to tell them apart meredith
did
amazing on watch what happens i just
want to say like andy had
really only questions for her and like
she just explained everything
so like concisely because obviously she
doesn't have like an
infinite amount of time and just has an
answer for everything and i just was
really impressed by her i watched the
first 10 minutes and i agree meredith is
a queen
lisa was being a cutie and i was just
like okay and she seemed a little
nervous so i was like okay cute cute
and then andy asked them has your life
how has life changed for you since
joining the show like is it different in
salt lake city now like what is it like
in the town
and they were both like silent for a
second and lisa was like i don't think
it's really
changed that much but i love being on
the show and it was like
so it was so weird it was so weird why
not acknowledge i'm sure like
salt lake city is turned upside down by
that she was like i'm so happy to be on
the show and it was like
the exact thing that i've been worried
about with her yeah it's like
i don't know i felt like andy felt it
too i swear no andy
is like andy probably more than anyone
gets
inundated with like thirst monster
generals at that
he turns a corner i think he had a
moment where he was like
um what have we done what have we done
yeah and then meredith answered and she
was like yeah no
i'm definitely way busier this is like a
full-time job and a half and
um everyone knows who you come up to us
and recognize us and so she was just
like honest and
it's just like it was a glimpse that i
just could have lived like to not
acknowledge that like you were nobody
before
is like that's worrisome yeah and so you
should watch it just because
it's just like a weird thing and i
really i do want to i'm liking her on
the show so i'm just going to try and go
by that and i feel like watching that
and pretty like what's not to like but i
do need her to come around to whitney
and heather because i'm
just obsessed with them i think whitney
that's the crew so cute next week lala
ken and katie maloney oh my god
yes what lala and whitney i guess are
friends from utah life
because lala is 28 29 and when he's 30.
so i'm so excited for that by the way in
another life i know we keep saying we
could see
um that we could see la la in real
housewives of beverly hills we could
also see her now on real housewives of
salt lake city yeah
wait that's so interesting when they
showed the preview i was shook
i'm so excited and it does feel like
sundance like lisa is going to be
annoying yeah maybe we'll see her
element and will feel differently
jerry's still out for me on all of the
women because again like my opinion
really did change on the drama between
mary
and jen last night yeah because the
7-eleven comment was so bizarre
yeah um and honestly jen shaw's husband
like everyone needs a husband like genji
like someone who just [ __ ] grounds
you and like
is so like ethical and in like
he talks to her like probably how he
talks to his like college team like
just trying to like put them on like the
right path and i don't know i feel like
everyone needs someone like that in
their corner and i feel like she
actually has a really good marriage
um ain't it good to be the coach and
ain't it good to be the coach
um yeah literally that energy like she
is um
connie britton connie britton and he's
coach taylor yeah and he's just like
spitting truth but i do have to say like
mary i was really turned off on her
especially by the 711 comment and just
like
her general unwillingness to like stay
in a conversation do you know what i
mean she's like kind of messy and all
over the place um but when she sat down
for dinner
drinks with heather and started talking
about like why the
comment about grandmother [ __ ]
grandfather [ __ ] was like so hurtful
and she started to cry like
i really like i feel like there's a lot
we don't know
and like even just her like saying on tv
like when i had to marry my grandfather
like
i really didn't want to like yeah making
it seem like obviously i don't think
that this is normal but it's my life and
just like respected yeah
i actually felt really bad and also it's
not like she married her grandpa last
year like
it has been 20 years they have kids
grandpa loving
yeah and so just step grandpa love it
yeah so let it go one but two i also
feel like
and maybe we missed this but mary should
have brought that energy to her luncheon
where she asked everyone to be open and
she could have said to jen like instead
of waiting for the apology
she could have said to you this is why
it hurt me you said this about me and by
the way jen said it
to somebody not to her so maybe in jen's
mind she doesn't know that mary heard it
maybe
so if mary came to her and said i heard
that you said i'm a grand
father [ __ ] and i just want to tell
you why that hurts me
so much here is my story right maybe
they could have
seen each other like everyone showed up
to the luncheon and
mary told everyone to be open and honest
and mary just showed up defensive and
that's just not a good combination and
that's why it was so toxic yeah or maybe
like they hadn't gotten to marry x it
felt like they were starting at the
other end of the table they didn't get
to anyone they started with jen you know
they had lisa who was like talking about
her like um
her all of her success and then heather
was talking about something and then jen
and that's where last week's episode
ended i want to talk about heather for a
second okay
i actually feel like heather is like
such a good mom and i really appreciated
her refreshing take on like religion and
motherhood like just letting the kids
are now like old enough
to make their own decisions and like
letting them guide the way like not
forcing them to go to church
not forcing them not to go to church
she's like you want to go i'll go with
you but you don't want to go we don't
have to go i just felt like that was
very refreshing i really appreciated
seeing that and when her kids were like
worried about
what people would say like when they do
eventually show up and she was like well
that's not a reason to go or not to go
like
go because it was in your heart or don't
her younger daughter was funny as [ __ ]
like she
she's a character she's honestly like i
feel like even though i love her so much
meredith's son like is so thirsty
and they feel like he comes on the show
and like wants to be memed whereas like
heather's daughter just like
accidentally
was the star of last night's episode and
brooks is like quaking in his house like
he's so angry you know
i totally agree and next week with the
fashion show like i'm sorry
anytime there's a real housewives season
one fashion show
it's not good it's not good but it's
also a rite of passage like
it's if you're not at like some janky
you know
studio space with like a fake stage
making
the first ever salt lake city fashion
week like that's not a real franchise so
i do feel like
it will be cringy but it is truly a rite
of passage i
i agree but i i totally agree that
brooks is thirsty he's annoying me now
at first i thought it was funny and i
was annoying me
especially after seeing jen shaw in
episode one
wearing his designs and supporting him
and now he's like a housewife like he's
talking [ __ ]
she's [ __ ] wearing your clothes and
she wears the best like chanel
everything
a hundred percent that's disrespectful
also mary's outfit to dinner with
heather
mary's outfits are all over the place
but but this is what actually lisa said
on watch what happens live because
um she has great pieces she has great
pieces which she very much does
yes i agree um okay well that's all we
got for you anything you want to say
before we wrap up no red hat's episode
is out now so if you are
rdh that this episode is ending head
over to the redheads book club we have a
great episode and you never know it
might inspire you to read i've been
getting so many messages about people
who have read so much this year due to
the redheads and we just we love to see
it there are also new episodes of all of
our tnn shows
mood with lauren elizabeth the snatcher
if you're looking for some bachelor
recap
speaking of the bachelor we have raven
on alexis's uh podcast and margaret
josephs
so check out all the podcasts at cho's
new toast news network on our instagram
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast of the millennium
morning show where we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe give this video
a thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast we found so
it's a spotify itunes city or public
video i have already stopped all the
places where we listen podcasts find us
the morning shows leave five star
viewers
beautiful stunning and smart we are we
hope you have an amazing
day we'll see you tomorrow goodbye